[Music]
in mannchild news oh yeah my man Chow
submitted by freezing cold
she knows what oh it's not great at all
that's good you never had frozen G don't
you like stale it's like frozen grapes
oh it's even better really no I never
had oh it's gross because of the the
[ __ ] fat solidifies in it and it has
like it was like a weird fad film in
your mouth because oh you tried it no
because like when we went camping and
[ __ ] you know it's like super cold like
I when you eat like Doritos Cheetos or
any of those chips
it tastes like solid grease I love that
stuff or like we can have like spare
ribs left over and they've been chilling
in the fridge and all the fatty parts
just become white and you're like nobody
thinks that dammit well man I'm just
weird I like butter
everybody likes butter everybody likes
booth pork better that's a pot and
welcome the home we don't talk about
Paula Deen yeah everybody disowned Paula
Deen do because she liked to dress
people up as slaves and I was a huge
bummer a man wrecked his own home with
an axe
in a childish rage that sounds that
sounds no real quick let's put that away
was it an Asian man Japanese men with
black glasses
who's this culprit cuz I know a bunch of
Asian dads that wreck their own house
all the time with the axe though that's
a stupid word but they're [ __ ] pissed
you work so hard to like to scrounge up
all this [ __ ] loose change to buy a
house and then you're the only one
that's [ __ ] I know what's interesting
is my my dad never broke things I don't
know where I learned that from but my
doors have been hurt a lot with holes in
walls you should record yourself raging
and I think you would change your ways
you'd be like well I'll go viral and be
rewarded for it oh yeah like to get a
record deal you know I've been watching
the mati condo [ __ ]
maricon Mariko I thought her name is
Marty kaan
nobody was usin it sounded like Marty
kaan dog yeah Marty kaan go
how do you say body Kondo I don't know
Marie Kondo is Marie Kondo I I was
messed up too because in the beginning I
a Japanese her name
tamati but it's like Marie it's not
Maddie it's Marie it's the way that it's
spelled I read I was like oh yeah well
I'm lady that's [ __ ] Mia because Mary
people called Muriel mati so maybe
that's why but either white like her she
you know like you go through [ __ ] and
then you she teaches you to see things
that are important right and so I found
out something very Johnny about myself I
kept something that was busted out of
pettiness so Muriel used to pissed me
off
I said bust my [ __ ] phones I kept one
in a nice little bag so I remember why I
kept this like to show her what she
makes me do and look at this and I was
gonna throw it away but I was like no
I'm not going [ __ ] joy could this
sparks joy does it spark rage it sparks
revenge and revenge sparks joy we know
how petty you are though yeah dude I
call myself petty [ __ ] damn it
revenge is the sweetest joy next to
getting place let's see yeah oh [ __ ]
they're doing the best philosophers know
I gotta get that [ __ ] on a [ __ ]
canvas tree and put it on my wall dude
yep all right so this dude here is 34
years old from Wisconsin I don't have
his name it's Mary yeah I'm [ __ ] up
her name I'm sorry I love you so much
she's watching this right now I know you
a piece of [ __ ] all right so yeah this
man child that we're talking about here
he thought that his wife did something
to his action figures I told you my
action figures not the action figure
Batman one swims in the bathtub you
can't mess with that yo he thought that
she damaged his toys he got a log
splitting ax and started to destroy his
whole his property so his furniture his
laptop the television
and the family's car windshield that's
weird
how come we didn't [ __ ] with her [ __ ]
maybe that's all her [ __ ] maybe I'm so
mad at you I'm gonna break my legs if
they read in any [ __ ] songs of them
like cool because I would go note her
makeup collection or burn her clothes
right why I'm putting myself in his
shoes if you [ __ ] with my action figures
I'm gonna go burn your makeup come on so
you care about and then I'll melt your
shoes it's like I for an i right like
he's just going further into damaging
his own let me explain why he couldn't
think that rationally yeah cuz she don't
have nothing because this man was drunk
oh well that'll do it huh I don't
understand angry drunk people cuz when I
drink I'm nice to everybody even people
I hate I'm nice in then are you the kind
of drunk guy that always tries to take
care of the bill pay for everybody I try
to pay for everybody and then I hug
people that I even hate when I'm drunk
though I'm down for anything
so a fun drunk and I feel loose I just
say yes to everything so if I'll pay for
everyone's bill I'll be really happy but
I feel like if someone bumps into no I'm
down a fight right then in there too oh
so you're just you just fill in the
spirit yes I feel the spirits everywhere
and then if I walk by oka table I'll
just throw down money and just gamble
and escrow is getting progressively like
more and more anxious as you're talking
like I just make out the homeless guy
anything say yes to anyone you look
sweet little slant on well you look
sweet too smelly man lucky lady but yeah
so this man caused about five thousand
dollars and damages that's it wait on a
car team or two laptop the car was a
windshield and he also chopped off both
side mirrors that's tight that makes
time that's not just like you and a rage
doing that it's kneeling huh and dig
this out and all right
you gotta run to the other side
the cops got there that axe was stuck in
the windshield
okay got it see you at one side Matthews
outside time and then how did it go down
like I just pictured this guy he gets
drunk and he's like it's time to play
with my Ninja Turtles you know like he's
like gonna go play with his Ninja
Turtles like oh my god what happened to
you were very she's older than him - so
he's 46 he's 34 how that was she didn't
ground him Wow
Duggars I feel so [ __ ] up one of one
of my friends so her his older sister is
now engaged to a guy that's like 10
years younger but we cuz we've known her
for so long we can't stop making like
young people jokes yeah so for example
like he doesn't have a job which makes
it ten times worse right yeah yeah so
when she got with him was he ever
employed well he just graduate I think
he just got a job recently like a mark
time job so now we just like crack jokes
at the guy all the time and it's hard
for me not to cuz I feel like for
example I for Thanksgiving he was like
oh can he come over I was like well did
he ask permission from you take it from
all of us because it's hard not to make
jokes at him at this point cuz my GOP
was like financially stable and
successful we can't say anything yeah
not cuz I hate them it's just cuz it's
too easy yeah and it's the friend's
responsibility if you make dumb choices
you have to the friends response it's so
bad dude I feel so [ __ ] up - cuz I
asked mr. fu if he passes SATs or not I
can't I can't [ __ ] help it dude it's
just so easy
well did he
well history test was and also the [ __ ]
how old is he he's like in his low 20s
so he's like not really what is your
friend in her 3000 class you know I'm
finally out I'm sick I'm saying things
that don't make sense like for example
low twenties right yeah I said the other
day 10 corrected me and he was laughing
because I I said look at that woman dog
and he was like I said yeah what is a
human dog know you know I was like like
he goes do you say female dog and I said
what do you mean he goes like you
wouldn't say like well look at that
[ __ ] woman dolphin and I looked at my
line oh it's called the mermaid let me
call this [ __ ] the wrong thing yeah
that's a lady dolphin Rossi oh yeah it's
the other [ __ ] [ __ ] up dude that's a
man vagina yeah a woman dog I said a
woman dog and that doesn't make any
sense
thanks to me our lady dog right you
would say that [ __ ] yeah yeah give me
the zip is out
it's agreeing with you you have a
problem zipper sound makes sense in the
that's just a Missy Elliott lyric when I
asked her for things it actually makes
sense I'll be like like let's say I get
my coffee and I'm like oh sugar damn it
I'm missing the zippers out any pass
Raymer yeah see there's enough context
really you know I'm talking abut there's
so much already on my own mind I don't
want to have to decipher what the [ __ ]
you're trying to put door ding-a-lings
away 20s dude come on dude that's like
that's like the weather yeah he's
mellowed
with Stephen who was not passed at this
18 yeah but basically he's in his low
20s yeah
and he has a woman dog okay you're in
your low IQs right now wait how how does
early IQs early I she did I got a
t-shirt on the speaks of English bald is
your lady friend huh
is she in at 30 35 Fahrenheit like 33
she's 33 33 fairs so there's like a 10
year difference I know it's not that's
tricky it's just kind of funny at this
point like I just I just kind of laugh
funny thing is she's actually more
mature than she is oh damn
which kind of [ __ ] hilarious though I
want you guys to me and just so you can
make fun of us that didn't know waiting
yeah oh he crashed at our spot because
he had a job interview in LA so is there
kind of floating around cuz I woke him
up I was like hey you sound like a
Superman designed into like just to make
that [ __ ] joke did set two alarms
[Music]
you
[Music]